[Music]
all right let's go to the phones this
hour it's a free call triple eight eight
two five five two two five mike joins us
in buffalo new york mike welcome to the
ramsay show
hey guys thanks for having me sure how
can we help
okay so i'm 28 um i'm um i'm living at
home i actually moved out
of a uh apartment that i was i was
living at um
just too much rent so i i decided to
move back um i got a little beater car
now
um
and you know i depleted my thousand
dollar emergency fund to get it
but now i
i want to move back out and i just don't
know
if i should be um saving up a thousand
before i move out or if i should
kind of treat this like um
sort of an emergency i guess why do you
want to move out
um
i'm in a relationship right now and it's
not uh not the best situation um
we you know we don't see each other too
much and it's just um
um
i feel like it's kind of putting a
strain on things to be honest yeah
um
are you safe at
home yeah no it's it's great i mean as
far as
um you know i have a great relationship
with my parents it's just um
you know everything outside of that
it sounds to me like you're gonna trade
one strain for another
that you're going to trade
financial strain get your feet under you
i mean what what are we talking we're
talking like three more months 90 more
days 120 days
of yeah hammering it
like
man if your relationship can't if you're
with somebody and they and you say hey
man for the next three or four months
i'm gonna i'm gonna make a move that's
gonna change our future forever my
future forever and they're not
all in your corner 100 percent then that
that bodes that's that's a that's a
that's a shadow over your relationship
um
if you run out for this new relationship
um you're gonna not be able to go out
you're gonna find yourself in debt
you're gonna end up back in these same
places and then at some point i'm my
brother i'm telling you you're going
back at your parents house i'd much
rather see you just suck it up and get
this thing knocked out
okay mike what's your income right now
um i
um i got a i got a new job about two
months ago i'm making about 40k a year
okay
you need to save this baby step one in a
few weeks
and it may mean taking some extra side
jobs right now baby step one is very
fast so no you there's no pausing baby
step one it's a number of days so
there's no pausing here dude you have
zero dollars to your name yeah and you
don't even pay rent how are you able to
save this thing up so fast how old are
you
i'm 28. how much debt do you have
uh about just under 30 000.
yeah man
there's something i'm not i'm missing
because you've got crisis in your voice
and the numbers aren't telling me crisis
what's the panic
so i mean the past couple years i mean
i've been listening to you guys for you
know for about three years you know dave
and everybody else um i've i've
i've wanted to do
you know follow the plan um
i actually just joined fpu just
yesterday i'm doing online class and you
know i i want to take this more serious
because
um
you know it just seems like with you
know relationships and and
even even work life has just been so
volatile the past couple couple of years
even before the pandemic started that's
right so here's
let's let today be the day
what's the day beat the day man
i don't want you calling back in three
more years saying well it's just been a
crazy time that's right dude life's
crazy you need some stability in your
life and that means getting that baby
step one paying off your debt and then
we can focus on moving out and focusing
on this relationship you're too broke to
be in a relationship right now you can't
breathe and you need some little wins
brother you signed up that's a win you
need to get that thousand dollar
emergency fund this month that's a win
we're gonna keep inching towards this
thing okay i'm proud of you
today's the day